Narrator:
WELCOME TO THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESS.
PAY ATTENTION, MEN.
WHOO!
DO IT AGAIN.
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
Nick: A DREAM WOKE ME UP
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
IT WAS A VISION
OF SOMETHING REVOLUTIONARY.
...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
IF I OFFERED YOU
$30 MILLION FOR THE COMPANY,
WOULD YOU TAKE IT?
NO.
OH!
Narrator: ...AND FIGHT
EACH OTHER FOR A DEAL.
THE NUMBERS
AREN'T ADDING UP.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BE
STUCK ON THE NUMBERS.
WHY NOT?
Narrator: BUT THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR, OR THEY'LL
WALK AWAY WITH NOTHING.
I'VE DONE A HALF-MILLION
DOLLARS' WORTH OF SALES.
WOW.
OUR PROFIT IS NEGATIVE.
THAT SUCKS!
WHAT STOPS SOMEBODY WHO ACTUALLY
KNOWS HOW TO DO THIS
AND CRUSH YOU
LIKE THE COCKROACH THAT YOU ARE?
I'M NOT A COCKROACH.
[ CHUCKLES ]
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT FROM
WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2 BILLION REAL-ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
RENOWNED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
I'M ARUM.
I'M DAWOON.
I'M SOO.
All:
AND WE'RE THE KANG SISTERS FROM
SAN FRANCISCO, CALIFORNIA.
THESE SMELL REALLY GOOD.
IT'S FRENCH LAVENDER.
WOW, THAT'S AMAZING.
THE THREE OF US WERE
BORN AND RAISED IN KOREA.
AND WHEN WE WERE TEENAGERS,
WE IMMIGRATED TO AMERICA.
I WENT
TO STANFORD BUSINESS SCHOOL.
AND I WENT
TO HARVARD BUSINESS SCHOOL.
TO PARSONS SCHOOL OF DESIGN.
OUR DAD SACRIFICED
SO MUCH
TO SEND THREE OF US TO SCHOOL
IN THE U.S.
FINANCIALLY,
HE HAD TO WORK ALL THE TIME.
AND THE FACT THAT HE HAD TO
JUST LET HIS DAUGHTERS GO
AT SUCH A YOUNG AGE,
I THINK THAT WAS REALLY HARD
FOR THEM.
DAWOON,
HOW WAS YOUR DATE?
HE TEXTS ME,
BUT HE'S NOT ASKING ME OUT --
ON A SECOND DATE.
YEAH.
ONE DAY AT LUNCH, WE WERE
DISCUSSING A COMMON PROBLEM
AND CAME UP WITH A SOLUTION
IN THE TECH SPACE
THAT COULD
REALLY WORK.
CHEERS.
WE QUIT OUR HIGH-PAYING JOBS
AND MOVED TO SAN FRANCISCO.
AND WE JUST STARTED
OUR OWN BUSINESS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT OUR
UPCOMING MARKETING INITIATIVE.
Arum: WE BELIEVE WE HAVE
SOMETHING VERY BIG ON OUR HANDS,
SOMETHING THAT CAN
POTENTIALLY CHANGE LIVES.
Soo: WITHOUT THE MONEY
FROM THE SHARKS,
WE WON'T BE ABLE TO EXECUTE
OUR GROWTH PLAN,
NOT TO MENTION TO DISAPPOINT
OUR FAMILY
AFTER ALL THAT
THEY HAVE SACRIFICED.
HELLO!
MY NAME IS ARUM.
DAWOON.
AND SOO.
All: AND WE'RE THE KANG SISTERS
FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
[ CHUCKLES ]
TODAY,
WE'RE RAISING $500,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 5% EQUITY
IN OUR COMPANY.
COFFEE MEETS BAGEL IS HERE
TO PROFOUNDLY CHANGE
HOW PEOPLE DISCOVER
AND FALL IN LOVE.
SHARKS, I KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE THINKING.
[ CHUCKLES ]
"IT'S ANOTHER
DATING SITE."
WE ALL KNOW
ONLINE DATING SUCKS.
WHY? BECAUSE IT TREATS PEOPLE
AS A PIECE OF INFORMATION
YOU SEARCH FOR
FROM A HUGE DATABASE.
PEOPLE WANT TO GO BACK TO TIME
OF HAPPENSTANCE
WHERE YOU JUST STUMBLE UPON
SOMEONE SPECIAL,
MAYBE THROUGH A FRIEND.
THAT'S WHY WE CREATED
COFFEE MEETS BAGEL.
WE TOOK THE PROVEN CONCEPT
OF DAILY FLASH CELL SITES
AND MERGED IT
WITH SOCIAL-NETWORKING ELEMENTS
TO CREATE THE HIGHEST-QUALITY
DATING SERVICE FOR SINGLES.
Soo:
HERE IS HOW IT WORKS.
EVERY DAY AT NOON,
WE CURATE ONE PERFECT MATCH
WHO IS A FRIEND OF A FRIEND.
YOU HAVE 24 HOURS TO REVIEW
THEIR PROFILE INFORMATION
AND CHOOSE TO LIKE OR PASS
ON THE MATCH.
MUTUAL LIKE LEADS
TO A PRIVATE CHAT LINE
THAT EXPIRES
IN SEVEN DAYS.
THE SECRET TO SUCCESS
IN ONLINE DATING
IS WINNING OVER WOMEN.
[ LAUGHS ]
SINGLE WOMEN ARE TIRED OF
SIGNING UP FOR DATING WEBSITES
ONLY TO GET HIT ON
BY CREEPY STRANGERS
BOMBARDING THEM
WITH DISGUSTING MESSAGES.
Cuban: KEVIN!
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND THAT IS WHY WOMEN LOVE
COFFEE MEETS BAGEL.
SINCE OUR NATIONAL LAUNCH,
WE'VE BEEN GROWING
AT DOUBLE DIGITS MONTHLY.
AND NOW, WITH YOUR HELP
AND INVESTMENT,
WE CAN HELP SINGLES
ALL AROUND THE WORLD.
SO, SHARKS...
All: WHO'S GOING TO BE
OUR PERFECT MATCH?
Greiner: [ CHUCKLES ]
SO, THIS IS VERY INTERESTING.
O'Leary: WHAT DOES THE BAGEL
GOT TO DO WITH IT?
LET'S JUST BE HONEST.
THERE IS STILL A LITTLE BIT
OF STIGMA WITH ONLINE DATING.
SO, OUR CUSTOMERS ACTUALLY LOVE
THE FACT
THAT OUR NAME DOESN'T SEEM TO,
YOU KNOW,
DO ANYTHING WITH DATING SERVICE.
WHEN THEY TALK ABOUT IT,
NOBODY REALLY KNOWS
WHAT THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT.
"HEY, I GOT AN EVERYTHING BAGEL
TODAY!"
[ Disappointed ] "TODAY,
I GOT A STALE BAGEL TODAY."
IT'S LIKE A CODE FOR THEM.
[ CHUCKLES ]
OH.
THAT'S CLEVER.
SO, TELL US
ABOUT YOUR BUSINESS MODEL.
Arum:
OUR CORE SERVICE IS FREE,
BUT THERE IS PREMIUM FEATURES
THAT YOU CAN UNLOCK
USING VIRTUAL CURRENCY
IN THE FORM OF COFFEE BEANS.
LIKE WHAT?
ONE OF THE MOST POPULAR ITEMS
WE HAVE
IS CALLED OPEN SESAME.
WE ACTUALLY TELL YOU
HOW MANY MUTUAL FRIENDS
YOU HAVE BETWEEN
YOU AND YOUR MATCH,
BUT WE DON'T TELL YOU
WHO THEY ARE.
WHAT GOOD IS THAT?
O'Leary: WELL, YOU BUY IT.
IT'S THE MYSTERY,
RIGHT?
YOU BUY IT.
Arum: IT'S THE MYSTERY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WANT TO KNOW,
"HOW AM I CONNECTED
TO THIS PERSON?"
AND HOW MUCH DO I PAY
FOR THE COFFEE BEANS?
EACH BEAN IS EQUIVALENT
TO ABOUT 2 CENTS,
BUT OPEN SESAME, FOR EXAMPLE,
IT'S 95 BEANS.
DO BOTH PARTIES HAVE TO LIKE
EACH OTHER TO BE A MATCH?
EXACTLY. SO, THIS HAS TO BE
A MUTUAL CONSENT.
AND HOW DO YOU CURATE?
SO, WE HAVE A PROPRIETARY
MISSION LEARNING ALGORITHM
THAT TAKES INTO CONSIDERATION
ALL THE USERS' DATA.
AND WE REQUIRE ALL USERS
TO SIGN UP THROUGH FACEBOOK.
SO, INSTANTLY, FROM DAY ONE,
WE CAN LEARN
A LOT ABOUT THE USER,
INCLUDING THEIR FRIENDS.
BUT YOU ONLY SOURCE
FROM FACEBOOK.
YOU DON'T USE
A QUESTIONNAIRE.
WE DON'T DO ANY OF THAT
RIGHT NOW.
SO, IT LITERALLY TAKES, LIKE,
LESS THAN A MINUTE TO SIGN UP.
THE IDEA IS, YOU DON'T HAVE TO
MAKE SOMEONE
GO THROUGH
THE APPLICATION PROCESS.
Herjavec: THE FORM.
EXACTLY. EXACTLY.
MOST IMPORTANT QUESTION.
HAVE YOU MET THE MAN
OF YOUR DREAMS?
[ CHUCKLES ]
SO, ARUM HERE IS MARRIED
WITH A GUY THAT SHE MET
LONG, LONG TIME AGO.
YES.
I MET MY CURRENT BOYFRIEND
ON COFFEE MEETS BAGEL.
YOU SEE THE PICTURES
OF THE TWO OF US ON THE WALL.
I'M MEETING A LOT OF, YOU KNOW,
INTERESTING PEOPLE
THROUGH
COFFEE MEETS BAGEL.
AND I'M STILL LOOKING.
ALL RIGHT.
HOW MANY USERS?
SO, RIGHT NOW, WE HAVE
SEVERAL HUNDRED THOUSAND USERS.
OUR BUSINESS
REALLY RAMPED UP --
IS IT 200,000
OR IS IT 700,000?
SO, IT'S BETWEEN
100,000 AND 500,000.
Corcoran:
100,000 AND 500,000 WHAT?
WHY DON'T YOU JUST TELL US
WHAT IT IS?
YOU WANT AN INVESTMENT,
YOU CAN'T NOT TELL US.
YES, BUT I THINK
THAT'S A GOOD RANGE.
IT GIVES YOU A GOOD IDEA.
NO, IT DOESN'T.
NO, BUT WHY WON'T YOU GIVE US
THE ACTUAL NUMBER?
WE'RE ACTUALLY NOT SHARING
THE EXACT USER NUMBER
RIGHT NOW
FOR COMPETITIVE --
OKAY, I'M OUT.
I'M OUT.
YOU'VE GOT TO SHARE THAT.
ARE YOU KIDDING?
OKAY.
WHAT WERE YOUR SALES?
SO, LAST YEAR,
WE MADE $87,000.
BUT GET THIS --
THIS YEAR,
IN THE FIRST FIVE MONTHS,
WE MADE $270,000.
WOW.
SO, IT'S GROWING
VERY QUICKLY.
WHAT DO YOU FORECAST
FOR THIS CALENDAR YEAR, ALL-IN?
AT THIS CURRENT RATE,
WE WILL MAKE $1 MILLION.
IMPRESSIVE.
AND NEXT YEAR,
WE AIM TO MAKE
$10 MILLION.
ALL RIGHT, FROM
THE MILLION DOLLARS IN SALES,
WHAT WILL YOU MAKE?
WHAT'S YOUR PROFIT?
SO, RIGHT NOW,
OUR PROFIT IS NEGATIVE
BECAUSE WE HAD TO SPEND
A LOT OF MONEY,
MOSTLY ON SALARIES,
TO PAY OUR DEVELOPERS.
AND DO YOU GUYS TAKE A SALARY
TODAY?
RIGHT NOW
WE TAKE $100,000 SALARY EACH.
EACH?
WOW.
SORRY.
YOU TAKE $100,000 EACH?
SO $300,000 YOU'RE DRAWING OUT
OF THE BUSINESS RIGHT NOW.
Soo: A YEAR.
Arum: A YEAR.
BUT THAT IS STILL A SIGNIFICANT
PAY CUT FOR ALL OF US,
WHATEVER
WE WERE MAKING PRIOR.
Herjavec: [ LAUGHS ]
WE ACTUALLY RAISED $2.8 MILLION
IN EXTERNAL FUNDING SO FAR.
WOW.
HOW?
OUR NOTABLE INVESTOR, ACTUALLY,
IS ONE OF THE CO-FOUNDERS
OF Match.com,
WHO ABSOLUTELY LOVED OUR IDEA.
AND HE WAS
OUR VERY FIRST INVESTOR.
ON THE $1 MILLION, HOW MUCH
WILL YOU LOSE THIS YEAR?
WE'LL LOSE $1 MILLION.
YOU'LL LOSE $1 MILLION ON
$1 MILLION IN SALES THIS YEAR?
YES. WHICH IS WHY WE ACTUALLY
HAVE TO RAISE MORE MONEY
BECAUSE WE ARE TRYING TO RAMP UP
OUR GROWTH.
YOU'RE PROJECTING $10 MILLION
FOR THE SECOND YEAR.
EXACTLY.
HOW MUCH MONEY WILL YOU MAKE
ON THAT $10 MILLION?
WE WILL BREAK EVEN
ON $10 MILLION.
YOU'LL BREAK EVEN
ON $10 MILLION?
WOW.
LET HER GO. LET HER GO.
GO AHEAD. TELL US.
Dawoon: HERE'S WHY.
WE PLAN TO BRING ON
ABOUT 4 MILLION USERS NEXT YEAR,
WHICH IS GOING TO GENERATE
ABOUT $2.50 EACH,
HENCE THE $10 MILLION.
AND WHAT'S YOUR
CUSTOMER ACQUISITION COST?
30 CENTS.
NEXT YEAR, WE PLAN ON SPENDING
ABOUT $3 MILLION TO $4 MILLION
ON MARKETING SPENDING
AND ACQUIRE 4 MILLION USERS.
SO, WE ARE ASSUMING
A SLIGHT INCREASE
IN CUSTOMER ACQUISITION COST.
YOU KNOW,
YOU'RE AN ALL-OR-NOTHING PLAY.
WHY DO YOU THINK
WE'RE ALL-OR-NOTHING?
BECAUSE YOU'RE LOSING
SO MUCH MONEY.
YOU'RE NOT REALLY IN
THE "BUILDING A BUSINESS" GAME,
YOU'RE IN THE "RAISING MONEY
AND GETTING USERS" GAME.
I THINK YOU'VE GOT TO HIT
A HOME RUN.
I'M NOT SAYING YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO, BUT IT'S RISKY.
I'M OUT.
IT IS OUR DECISION
TO INVEST MORE NOW
SO WE CAN ACCELERATE GROWTH,
BUT WE CAN JUST AS WELL
JUST GROW THIS BUSINESS AS IS.
THAT'S THE FASCINATING
DILEMMA, 'CAUSE I HEAR
WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM.
THE BASELINE MODEL WORKS.
YOU WANT TO POUR GASOLINE
ON THAT FIRE.
EXACTLY.
IT'S A PRETTY BIG BET.
AND WHILE I'M DOING IT, I PART
WITH $500,000 AND I GET 5%.
ONE OF THE PROBLEMS FOR ME NOW
ON "SHARK TANK" IN SEASON 6 IS,
I'VE COME TO REALIZE
I'M REALLY VALUABLE.
BIG TIME.
[ CHUCKLES ]
AND IT'S MADE ME
VERY GREEDY.
I DON'T DO 5% DEALS.
THAT'S WORTHLESS TO ME.
I WOULDN'T DO THIS.
I'M OUT.
IF WE REALLY THOUGHT THIS
WAS ALL-OR-NOTHING,
WE WOULD HAVE RAISED A LOT
MORE MONEY FROM THE BEGINNING.
NOW WE ACTUALLY HAVE A CHOICE
OF JUST GROWING
THE BUSINESS TRADITIONALLY
OR RAISE MORE MONEY
TO MAKE THIS BIG.
YOU'VE RAISED A LOT OF MONEY,
AND YOU'RE NOT MAKING MONEY,
AND YOU'RE EACH
DRAWING $100,000 --
THAT'S $300,000
OUT OF THE BUSINESS.
THAT SEEMS
VERY HIGH SALARY.
I MEAN, MOST PEOPLE DON'T MAKE
ANYWHERE NEAR THAT.
AND YOU'RE JUST GROWING.
BIG CONCERN I HAVE, ALSO,
IS THE FACT THAT SOMEBODY ELSE
COULD DO THIS.
PEOPLE ARE KNOCKING OFF
EVERYBODY
ON THE INTERNET
ALL THE TIME.
SO, FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
I THINK ONE THING FOR SURE IS
YOU ARE GREAT AT RAISING MONEY.
THANK YOU.
I ALSO THINK
THIS IS A SITE THAT'S NEEDED.
I THINK THE WOMEN I KNOW THAT
HAVE BEEN ON THE TYPICAL WEBSITE
FEEL LIKE A PIECE OF MEAT
IN A MEAT LOCKER.
EXACTLY.
TOTALLY.
THEY'RE LOOKED OVER.
YOU KNOW,
IT'S ALMOST INSULTING.
YES.
THIS IS A SITE THAT GIVES WOMEN
A LITTLE BIT MORE CONTROL.
AND I LIKE ALL OF THAT.
BUT I'LL TELL YOU
WHAT I DON'T LIKE --
THE BREAK EVEN AT $10 MILLION.
A BREAK EVEN!
AND I'M ONLY OWNING
5% OF THE STOCK.
THAT'S SPOOKY.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
ENOUGH UP-SIDE
FOR THE ENORMOUS RISK
I'D BE TAKING.
SO, FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
LET ME ASK YOU
A QUESTION.
IF I OFFERED YOU $30 MILLION
FOR THE COMPANY,
WOULD YOU TAKE IT?
Narrator:
ALL FIVE SHARKS ARE OUT,
BUT MARK CUBAN HAS JUST MADE
THE LARGEST OFFER
IN "SHARK TANK" HISTORY.
Cuban: LET ME ASK YOU
A QUESTION.
I IF I OFFERED YOU
$30 MILLION FOR THE COMPANY,
WOULD YOU TAKE IT?
NO.
OKAY.
I WOULD NOT BE TAKING IT
BECAUSE WE SEE --
WE SEE THIS BUSINESS GROWING
AS BIG AS Match.com.
AND YOU KNOW HOW MUCH REVENUE
THEY ARE GENERATING?
$800 MILLION A YEAR.
THEY'RE BECOMING A
BILLION-DOLLAR REVENUE COMPANY.
AND WE THINK THIS MODEL
AND THE PRODUCT
HAS POTENTIAL TO BE
AS BIG AS MATCH.
HE OFFERED YOU $30 MILLION,
AND YOU DIDN'T EVEN FLINCH.
Cuban:
SHE SHOULD FEEL CONFIDENT.
IT'S A NEWER EPHEMERAL VERSION
OF HOT OR NOT,
WHICH IS BRILLIANT.
BUT I DON'T KNOW
HOW PROTECTABLE THAT IS.
WHILE I GIVE YOU
TOTAL CREDIT
AND I THINK YOU GUYS HAVE DONE
SOME BRILLIANT THINGS,
I DON'T THINK THE RISK/REWARD
IS THERE FOR ME,
AND FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M STILL OUT.
Greiner: GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU.
O'Leary:
EXCELLENT PRESENTATION.
Arum:
WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT THEY SAY --
LIKE IN DATING, NEVER SETTLE.
WHILE $30 MILLION MAY SOUND LIKE
A LOT OF MONEY,
YOU WAIT, MR. MARK CUBAN,
BECAUSE THIS BABY
IS GOING TO EXPLODE.
Narrator: IN SEASON 5,
PETE HAMBORG, HIS SON, GUS,
AND THEIR COUSIN DONNIE SANDUSKY
INTRODUCED THE SHARKS
TO THEIR SKATEBOARDING
INNOVATION.
$300,000, 30%.
ROBERT, WE WANT TO DO BUSINESS
WITH YOU.
ALL RIGHT!
Narrator: LET'S SEE
WHAT THEY'RE UP TO NOW.
"SHARK TANK" IS THE BEST
THING THAT'S EVER HAPPENED
TO OUR BUSINESS.
IN THE YEAR LEADING UP
TO OUR PITCH,
WE HAD DONE ABOUT $225,000
IN SALES.
A YEAR AFTER "SHARK TANK,"
OUR TOTAL SALES HAVE EXCEEDED
$1 MILLION.
WE'RE PROUD TO SAY
WE'RE CONTINUING
TO MAKE OUR PRODUCTS
BY HAND
HERE IN HUNTINGTON BEACH,
CALIFORNIA.
THE COMPANY'S GROWING
PRETTY MUCH AS FAST
AS WE CAN HANDLE IT.
WE'VE DOUBLED
OUR WAREHOUSE SPACE,
WE'VE ADDED
THREE NEW EMPLOYEES,
AND WE'VE BUILT A COMPLETELY
NEW INTERNET WEB STORE.
HEY, GUYS!
HEY!
PETE, DONNIE, AND GUS
ARE KILLING IT.
$1 MILLION IN SALES
IN SUCH A SHORT AMOUNT
OF TIME -- IT'S INCREDIBLE.
YOU KNOW, NEXT STEP
IS $2 MILLION, $3 MILLION.
WE JUST GOT TO BE REALLY CAREFUL
WITH INVENTORY CONTROL.
Sandusky:
ROBERT AND HIS TEAM HAVE BEEN
WONDERFUL BUSINESS PARTNERS
AND COACHES.
THEY SET US UP ON A CLEAR PATH
TO GROW RESPONSIBLY,
AND THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT WE NEEDED.
HEY, CAN WE GO TRY THEM
ON THE BEACH?
LET'S DO IT.
Pete: WE DO STREET SURFING
BETTER THAN ANYBODY ELSE.
AND WHAT
WE'VE INADVERTENTLY DONE
IS WE'VE STARTED
A WHOLE NEW SPORT --
STREET STAND-UP PADDLING.
WE'RE ON THE GROUND FLOOR
OF A MOVEMENT THAT'S STARTING.
GOSH.
YEP, THIS LOOKS GREAT.
THANK YOU.
BECAUSE OF "SHARK TANK,"
WE'RE STRONGER AS A FAMILY
AND AS A BUSINESS.
WE WOULDN'T TRADE IT
FOR ANYTHING.
Herjavec:
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU CAN START
A BUSINESS WITH YOUR KIDS
AND BUILD
A MILLION-DOLLAR BUSINESS,
THAT IS THE AMERICAN DREAM.
THAT'S WHAT "SHARK TANK"
IS ALL ABOUT.
AND I'M HAPPY TO BE PART
OF THEIR DREAM.
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A PRODUCT DESIGNED
TO MAKE WOMEN LOOK
CLASSY AND SEXY.
HI, SHARKS.
I'M JULIE KALIMIAN.
I LIVE IN NEW YORK.
MY COMPANY IS SkinnyShirt,
AND I AM SEEKING $100,000
FOR 20% OF MY BUSINESS.
LADIES, HAS THIS EVER HAPPENED
TO YOU?
YOU PUT ON YOUR FAVORITE
BUTTON-DOWN SHIRT
AND A GORGEOUS SWEATER,
AND, UGH!
INSTEAD OF LOOKING
SLEEK AND SLIM,
YOU LOOK BUNCHY AND BULKY
INSTEAD?
SkinnyShirt
TO THE RESCUE.
I HAVE COMBINED TWO ALL-TIME
FAVORITE CLOTHING ITEMS --
THE CLASSIC BUTTON-DOWN SHIRT
AND THE STRETCHY KNIT CAMI
TO ELIMINATE THE BULK.
BUT SINCE SEEING IS BELIEVING,
KRISTIN HERE
IS GONNA TAKE OFF
HER TRADITIONAL SHIRT
AND SLIP ON A SkinnyShirt
TO SHOW YOU
EXACTLY WHAT A BIG DIFFERENCE
SkinnyShirt CAN MAKE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Greiner:
YOU JUST GOT THEIR ATTENTION.
Corcoran: OH, BOYS.
NOW REALLY
GOT YOUR ATTENTION.
Herjavec: [ HUMMING ]
LAYERING IS A CLASSIC
AND EASY WAY TO DRESS.
[ LAUGHS ]
BUT NOBODY LIKES IT
WHEN THE LAYERS
MAKE YOU LOOK BIGGER
THAN YOU ACTUALLY ARE.
SO, SAY GOODBYE
TO THAT BULKY SHIRT...
Corcoran: PAY ATTENTION, MEN.
HERE WE GO.
...AND SAY
HELLO TO SkinnyShirt.
SORRY. THERE'S A SHIRT
IN HERE SOMEWHERE?
[ LAUGHS ]
SkinnyShirt CAN BE PAIRED
WITH V-NECKS,
CREW NECKS, BLAZERS,
CARDIGANS, SHIFT DRESSES,
AND IT'S EVEN CUTE ENOUGH
TO BE WORN ALONE.
NOW, THAT WAS EFFECTIVE.
[ LAUGHS ]
GREAT PRESENTATION THERE.
THANK YOU.
DO IT AGAIN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
KRISTEN, COME ON OUT HERE.
WOW.
NOW, SHARKS, LET'S TAKE A LOOK
AT THE BEFORE AND AFTER.
WHO IS THAT?
[ LAUGHTER ]
AS I'M SURE
YOU WILL ALL AGREE,
KRISTEN LOOKS
MORE PULLED TOGETHER,
NOT TO MENTION SLEEKER,
SMOOTHER, SLIMMER, SEXIER.
SO, NOW,
WHICH ONE OF YOU SHARKS
WANTS TO MAKE A FAT PROFIT
ON MY SkinnyShirt?
CAN YOU HAND US ONE OF THE
PACKAGES SO WE CAN CHECK IT OUT?
YES.
KRISTEN HAS ONE
FOR EVERYBODY.
Herjavec:
IS IT JUST A SPORTY MATERIAL
THAT BRINGS THE SHIRT IN?
IS THAT WHY IT'S --
SO, IT'S A STRETCHY KNIT CAMI.
IT'S A SHAPER
OR NOT A SHAPER?
IT IS.
O'Leary: THANK YOU.
IT FEEL LIKE A SECOND SKIN,
BUT IT ALSO SMOOTHES YOU OUT
AND HOLDS YOU IN.
Herjavec:
IS THE DESIGN OF IT UNIQUE
OR IS THE MATERIAL UNIQUE?
OR IS IT NOT UNIQUE?
IT IS UNIQUE.
AND THERE'S NOTHING LIKE THIS
ON THE MARKETPLACE.
WELL,
I'M ASSUMING IT'S UNIQUE.
IT IS 100% UNIQUE.
WHAT ARE YOUR SALES,
JULIE?
IN THE LAST THREE YEARS,
I'VE DONE A HALF-MILLION
DOLLARS' WORTH OF SALES.
WOW.
THIS YEAR, I'M ON TRACK
FOR $200,000.
WHAT WAS
JUST LAST YEAR ALONE?
LAST YEAR ALONE WAS $50,000.
WAIT, SO YOU WENT DOWN?
YES,
BECAUSE A TRUSTED FRIEND
INTRODUCED ME TO AN
UNTRUSTWORTHY MANUFACTURER.
AND I HAD TO EAT A LOT OF
BAD PRODUCTION, UNFORTUNATELY.
AND IT TOOK A WHILE
TILL I FOUND A NEW MANUFACTURER
I FELT COMFORTABLE WITH.
SO, I GUESS YOUR TRUSTED FRIEND
ISN'T SO TRUSTWORTHY.
YOU KNOW WHAT? HE THOUGHT
HE WAS DOING ME A FAVOR,
BUT APPARENTLY --
Corcoran:
BUT YOUR FRIEND INTRODUCED YOU,
BUT YOU HIRED
THE MANUFACTURER.
RIGHT.
AND THEY HAD HAD
A GOOD TRACK RECORD.
HAVE YOU SOLVED THAT PROBLEM?
YES.
I HAVE A MANUFACTURER ALREADY
SOURCED IN ASIA WHO CAN --
MY PRODUCT RIGHT NOW,
I'M MANUFACTURING IT
FOR $12.75 A SHIRT
FOR THE SLEEVELESS.
THIS ONE?
YEAH. I HAVE SOMEBODY
WHO'S WILLING TO DO $9.50.
JULIE,
WHAT DO YOU SELL IT FOR?
$68 FOR THE SLEEVELESS
AND $76 FOR THE LONG SLEEVE.
Greiner: WOW.
AND HOW DO YOU SELL THEM?
2/3 OF MY SALES
ARE ON MY WEBSITE,
AND 1/3
IS THROUGH WHOLESALERS.
I'VE GOT 75 BOUTIQUES
IN THE U.S. AND CANADA.
AND I HAD AN ORDER FOR ONE
PARTICULAR TV RETAILER THAT,
THE DAY IT WAS MEANT TO SHIP,
THIS UNTRUSTWORTHY MANUFACTURER
CALLED ME AND SAID,
"I ONLY HAVE HALF YOUR ORDER."
SO,
YOU HAD A QUALITY ISSUE
AND YOU HAD A DELIVERY ISSUE
FROM ONE PERSON.
SO, WHEN I LAUNCHED --
RIGHT.
I LAUNCHED,
AND I DID ONE LARGE ORDER.
IS YOUR BACKGROUND
IN TEXTILES?
NO.
FASHION?
NOT AT ALL.
I SPENT OVER 15 YEARS IN THE
CORPORATE WORLD IN PUBLISHING
BEFORE I BECAME A STAY-AT-HOME
MOM WITH MY FOUR KIDS
AND HAD MY FIFTH BABY.
WOW.
THANK YOU.
Cuban:
HELP ME WITH THE NUMBERS.
HOW MUCH HAVE YOU DONE
YEAR-TO-DATE?
I'VE DONE $70,000.
OKAY.
SO, YOU'VE DONE $70,000
THIS YEAR.
LAST YEAR WE'LL "X" OUT,
RIGHT?
'CAUSE THAT WAS A PROBLEM.
BUT YOU HAD TWO YEARS PRIOR
TO THAT, RIGHT?
YES.
WHAT WAS THE YEAR BEFORE?
$150,000.
AND THE YEAR BEFORE THAT
WAS $350,000.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS GETTING TO,
RIGHT?
SO, YOU TALKED ABOUT
THIS HORRIFIC EXPERIENCE
IN MANUFACTURING.
YET, THE TWO YEARS PRIOR
TO THAT,
YOU DID FAR MORE BUSINESS
AND WERE AT A FASTER PACE
THAN YOU ARE THIS YEAR.
WHY DID IT FALL IN HALF
TO THE SECOND YEAR?
GREAT QUESTION.
I STOPPED WORKING
WITH THAT MANUFACTURER.
AND IT TOOK A LONG TIME
TO TEE UP A NEW MANUFACTURER.
AND ON TOP OF THAT --
OKAY, WAIT.
SOMETHING'S NOT --
SOMETHING'S NOT WORKING HERE.
WITH ALL THOSE CHALLENGES,
YOU DID MORE
IN THAT FIRST YEAR
THAN YOU'RE ON PACE TO DO
THIS YEAR.
BECAUSE I DON'T HAVE INVENTORY
TO MONETIZE.
THAT'S WHAT HAMPERING
THE SALES.
IT'S ALL LOGISTICS PROBLEMS.
NO, IT'S NOT!
MARK, LET ME --
MAYBE I CAN ANSWER IT THIS WAY.
OKAY.
THREE OF MY TOP WHOLESALERS
TOOK A YEAR HIATUS
'CAUSE I DIDN'T HAVE INVENTORY
TO SELL THEM.
BUT YOU JUST SAID
YOU HAD TO EAT INVENTORY.
BUT EATING THE INVENTORY
WAS UNSALABLE SHIRTS.
AND IT LASTED
TWO AND A HALF YEARS?
NO, IT LASTED ONE YEAR.
BUT THEN I DIDN'T HAVE
THE CAPITAL TO GO OUT
AND MAKE
A SIZEABLE ENOUGH ORDER.
IT HAMPERED MY ABILITY
TO SELL AND DELIVER PRODUCTS.
THE NUMBERS AREN'T ADDING UP,
IS WHERE I'M GOING.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BE STUCK
ON THE NUMBERS, THOUGH.
WHY NOT?
BECAUSE
SHE HAD BAD-QUALITY GOODS
SO SHE COULDN'T SELL THEM,
SO SHE HAD TO EAT IT.
LET'S STOP TALKING ABOUT
ALL THE PROBLEMS YOU HAD
WITH THE LOGISTICS.
IS THIS A GOOD IDEA OR NOT?
IF IT'S A GOOD IDEA,
WHAT STOPS SOMEBODY WHO
ACTUALLY KNOWS HOW TO MAKE
SHIRTS AND DELIVER THEM,
DO THIS
AND MAKE A LOT OF MONEY
AND CRUSH YOU LIKE THE COCKROACH
THAT YOU ARE?
OKAY. FIRST OF ALL,
I'M NOT A COCKROACH.
[ LAUGHS ]
AND SECONDLY --
YOU HAVE NO MARKET SHARE
OF MAYBE A GOOD IDEA.
OKAY.
IT IS PATENT-PENDING.
AND I'VE SOLD 10,000 SHIRTS.
I HAVE GREAT BRANDING.
I HAVE A GREAT TRADEMARK.
I'M HERE BECAUSE I NEED
SOME CAPITAL FOR TWO REASONS --
FOR MANUFACTURING CONTACTS
AND DISTRIBUTION CONTACTS.
SO, I HAVE TO PAY FOR YOU
TO LEARN.
I'M NOT SAYING
YOU'RE A BAD PERSON.
IT'S JUST YOU'RE NOT A GOOD BET
FOR ME AS AN INVESTOR
BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
I DO KNOW WHAT --
NO, YOU DON'T.
YOU'VE BLOWN IT A COUPLE
OF TIMES IN THE LAST TWO YEARS.
BUT I'M --
Greiner:
SHE'S A BEGINNER.
I'M HERE --
I DON'T CARE. I DON'T CARE
IF YOU'RE A BEGINNER.
HOW SHE'S GONNA KNOW
JUST AUTOMATICALLY HOW
TO BE A MANUFACTURER?
I WANT TO MAKE MONEY.
I WANT TO MAKE MONEY!
AND I WANT TO MAKE MONEY.
WHY DON'T YOU JUST
ADMIT IT? YOU'VE NEVER
HAD 12 MONTHS IN A ROW
WHERE YOU'VE
LOGISTICALLY EXECUTED.
IF THERE WAS SOMETHING WRONG
WITH YOUR PRESENTATION,
75% OF IT WAS EXPLAINING
HOW YOU SCREWED UP, BASICALLY.
DON'T COME IN HERE TELLING ME
WHY YOU SCREWED UP.
TELL ME
HOW YOU'VE FIXED IT.
I'M OUT.
JULIE, I GIVE YOU CREDIT
FOR GETTING IT GOING.
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU WERE
ON A ROLL INITIALLY
AND THEN YOU
RAN INTO PROBLEMS
AND JUST HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE
TO REGROUP.
I JUST DON'T GET THE SENSE
THAT YOU HAVE A DEFINITIVE PLAN.
FOR THE PLAN, I HAVE LINED UP
AN OVERSEAS MANUFACTURER.
I NEED THE CAPITAL
TO PLACE THAT ORDER.
RIGHT.
THAT'S A CASH-MANAGEMENT ISSUE.
I DON'T THINK
GIVING YOU CASH
SOLVES YOUR ABILITY TO MANAGE
CASH AND DEAL WITH THOSE ISSUES.
I STILL THINK THE NUMBERS
DON'T ADD UP.
AND SO, FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
YOU GUYS LOOK FANTASTIC.
I THINK
IT'S A GOOD PRODUCT.
I DON'T KNOW
IF IT'S A STAND-ALONE CATEGORY.
BUT I DON'T THINK YOU HAVE
THE ANSWER TODAY.
AND, YOU KNOW, WHILE GETTING
AN INVESTMENT FROM -- FROM ME
OR ANYBODY HERE IS A JOURNEY,
BUT I NEED YOU TO KNOW WHERE
YOU'RE GOING DOWN THAT JOURNEY.
I DIDN'T SEE THAT TODAY.
I'M OUT.
I MEAN,
I THINK THERE'S MERIT TO IT.
PEOPLE LIKE SHAPERS.
MY PROBLEM IS,
IS I DON'T REALLY LIKE
THE LOOK OF A COLLARED SHIRT
UNDER A SWEATER.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH
PEOPLE WEAR THAT ANYMORE.
I'M NOT TRYING TO INSULT IT,
BUT I'M JUST --
I NEVER WEAR THAT LOOK.
AND BECAUSE I DON'T GET
THE FASHION STATEMENT THAT WELL,
I'M OUT.
Kalimian: BARBARA?
Corcoran:
ONE THING I HAVE TO SAY,
YOU HELD YOUR GROUND HERE
VERY WELL TODAY.
THANK YOU.
AND YOU DON'T SEEM BOTHERED
BY THIS GUY ON MY LEFT
WHO'S A BULLY,
THE OTHER BULLY WHO GRILLED YOU
ON MONEY INSIDE AND OUT.
THANK YOU.
BUT THERE'S ONE THING
THAT REALLY BOTHERS ME.
OKAY.
AND THAT IS
THE TIME YOU SPENT
ON TALKING
ABOUT THE MISHAP YOU HAD
WITH THE WRONG MANUFACTURER.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT I'VE
LEARNED OVER ALL THE YEARS
OF BEING IN BUSINESS?
I FOUND THE ONLY DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE GREAT WINNERS
AND EVERYBODY ELSE
IS NOT THE HITS
BUT HOW LONG THEY TOOK
TO FEEL SORRY FOR THEMSELVES.
AND YOU KNOW
WHAT I THINK?
THAT'S YOUR ACHILLES' HEEL.
I'M OUT.
OKAY.
GOOD LUCK.
THANK YOU.
THIS IS NOT THE END
OF MY COMPANY AT ALL.
I KNOW THAT IT'S GONNA BE
A HUGE SUCCESS,
AND I THINK THAT THE SHARKS
ARE GONNA LOOK BACK
AND BE LIKE, "MM!" YOU KNOW?
"MAYBE WE DIDN'T CONNECT
THE DOTS ON THAT ONE,
BUT, WOW, GOOD FOR HER."
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS AN ENTREPRENEUR
WITH A SOLUTION TO A COMMON
PROBLEM WITH ONLINE SHOPPING.
HI, SHARKS.
I'M ZANDER ADELL, AND I'M FROM
SAN FRANCISCO, CALIFORNIA.
MY COMPANY IS
DOORMAN PACKAGE DELIVERY.
I'M SEEKING $250,000
FOR A 10% EQUITY IN THE COMPANY.
SO, EVERYBODY LOVES
SHOPPING ONLINE,
EXCEPT FOR THE PART
WHERE YOU ACTUALLY GET
THE STUFF YOU BOUGHT.
EITHER YOU GET A "MISSED
DELIVERY" STICKER ON YOUR DOOR
OR YOUR PACKAGE IS LEFT
ON YOUR FRONT PORCH
WHERE IT'S RAINED ON OR STOLEN,
OR YOU GET TO SPEND A SATURDAY
AT SOME PACKAGE PICK-UP CENTER
MILES FROM YOUR HOUSE.
WHAT IF YOU COULD GET
YOUR PACKAGED DELIVERED AT NIGHT
WHEN YOU'RE ACTUALLY HOME?
AND WHAT IF YOU COULD SCHEDULE
IT ALL FROM AN APP?
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BUILT.
DOORMAN IS
AN ON-DEMAND MOBILE SERVICE
THAT PROVIDES PACKAGE DELIVERY
ON YOUR SCHEDULE.
HERE'S HOW IT WORKS.
WHEN YOU SIGN UP,
YOU GET A NEW SHIPPING ADDRESS
THAT LETS YOU SEND ALL OF
YOUR PACKAGES TO OUR WAREHOUSE.
ONCE THEY ARRIVE, YOU GET
A NOTIFICATION ON YOUR PHONE.
YOU CAN NOW GET
YOUR PACKAGES DELIVERED
TILL MIDNIGHT SEVEN DAYS A WEEK.
THIS IS THE ULTIMATE SOLUTION
THAT FINALLY SOLVES
THE LAST THING WRONG
WITH THE QUARTER-TRILLION-DOLLAR
E-COMMERCE MARKET
IN THE UNITED STATES.
AND WE WOULD LOVE YOUR HELP
TO TAKE THIS NATIONWIDE.
I'D BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
ZANDER, HOW MUCH DO I PAY YOU
FOR AN AVERAGE PACKAGE?
IT'S $3.99 PER PACKAGE.
OR, IF YOU LIKE THE SERVICE,
IT'S 19 BUCKS A MONTH
FOR UNLIMITED.
Corcoran:
AND IT MAKES NO DIFFERENCE
WHAT SIZE THE PACKAGE IS?
RIGHT NOW,
WE HAVE DELIVERY LIMITS
BASED ON OUR CURRENT DEPOT.
40 POUNDS OR OVER,
3√ FEET ON A SIDE.
O'Leary:
WHAT CITY IS THIS OPERATING IN?
RIGHT NOW,
WE'RE ONLY IN SAN FRANCISCO.
HOW MANY SUBSCRIBERS
DO YOU HAVE?
WE JUST CAME OUT IN MAY.
AND WE NOW HAVE 300 CUSTOMERS
ON OUR PLATFORM.
THEY'VE SHIPPED 4,000 PACKAGES
THROUGH US.
HOW MUCH DID IT COST YOU
TO SET UP THAT MANY CUSTOMERS?
I PUT 50K OF MY OWN MONEY IN.
AND SINCE THEN, WE'VE TAKEN IN
220K OF CONVERTIBLE NOTES.
O'Leary:
SO, THE BUSINESS IS SUCCESSFUL.
THE CONCEPT HAS BEEN PROVEN.
I'M UPS, I'M FedEx.
I SIMPLY ADD THIS FEATURE
TO MY INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT'S NEVER GONNA HAPPEN.
I DON'T NEED YOUR ANSWER, MARK.
I WANT HIS.
EVEN IF ALL OF THEM DID IT,
YOU WOULD HAVE TO HAVE AN APP
FOR EVERY SINGLE CARRIER,
WHEREAS WE'RE AGNOSTIC.
THE ULTIMATE VISION
FOR THE COMPANY
IS TO HAVE A CHECKBOX
ON RETAIL SITES.
THAT'S A GOOD IDEA.
NOW, IF THAT WAS ON AMAZON,
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING.
RIGHT.
I AGREE.
Herjavec:
IT'S A GREAT IDEA,
BUT THE COST TO SET UP A FedEx
WAS MASSIVE.
SO, OUR DRIVERS ARE DRIVING
THEIR OWN CARS.
SO, WE JUST HAVE TO RENT
WAREHOUSE SPACE.
WE DON'T HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
COSTS OF FedEx OR UPS.
SO, ARE YOU GONNA DELIVER
AT A SPECIFIC TIME?
SO, WE HAVE DIFFERENT OPTIONS.
SO, OUR FIRST TWO PRICING PLANS
ARE TWO-HOUR DELIVERY WINDOWS.
YOU CAN PICK 6:00 TO 8:00,
8:00 TO 10:00, 10:00 TO 12:00.
BUT WE ALSO HAVE
ONE-HOUR WINDOWS.
Greiner:
I THINK IT IS A GREAT IDEA.
THANK YOU.
PACKAGES
ARE ALWAYS A PROBLEM,
AND I'M ALWAYS ORDERING
ONLINE.
YOU DON'T HAVE A DOORMAN,
LORI?
I DO HAVE A DOORMAN.
OH.
BUT I PURPOSELY STAY
IN A BUILDING WITH A DOORMAN
FOR PACKAGES, LITERALLY.
THAT'S THE ONLY REASON ANYONE
WANTS A DOORMAN ANYMORE.
YES.
BUT I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW YOU PLAN TO SCALE FROM THIS
BECAUSE I DO SEE IT
BEING A LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT
AS YOU KEEP GROWING
BECAUSE PEOPLE WON'T PARTNER
WITH YOU ONLINE UNLESS --
O'Leary: RIGHT. LORI, IT'S UBER.
IT'S UBER ALL OVER AGAIN.
CITY AT A TIME.
YEP.
Adell:
THE MAIN THING THAT ACTUALLY
MAKES OUR MARGINS BETTER
IS POPULATION DENSITY.
THE MORE CUSTOMERS WE HAVE,
THE CLOSER THOSE CUSTOMERS
ARE TO EACH OTHER
IN ANY ONE- OR TWO-HOUR
TIME FRAME,
THE MORE DELIVERIES WE CAN MAKE
AN HOUR, THE LOWER OUR COSTS.
RIGHT NOW, WE'RE DOING
80 DELIVERIES A NIGHT
WITH THREE DRIVERS.
SO, IT DOESN'T TAKE
A WHOLE LOT OF DRIVERS
FOR US TO DO A LOT OF SERVICE.
YOU GO TO NEW YORK
OR YOU COME TO L.A.,
TELL ME
THE MARKETING PLAN
FOR PEOPLE TO FIND OUT
YOU'RE HERE.
RIGHT NOW, IT'S COSTLY FOR US
TO FIND A CUSTOMER.
OUR BEST CHANNEL RIGHT NOW
IS FACEBOOK.
$37 PER CUSTOMER,
AND THAT'S A LOT.
WOW.
THAT'S A LOT.
DO YOU HAVE ANY AGREEMENTS
WITH THE FedExes OR UPSes?
NO.
WE WOULD LIKE TO.
WE'RE JUST NOT BIG ENOUGH YET.
WITH RETAIL SITES, WE CAN HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS VERY EASILY.
YOU NEED TO BE
ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
O'Leary:
NOT ALL OVER. SEVEN CITIES.
Adell:
WE NEED A FEW MORE BIG MARKETS.
SEVEN CITIES IS LIKE 50%.
RIGHT NOW, THE PLAN FOR
THE SECOND CITY IS CHICAGO.
Greiner: YES!
Corcoran: WE ALL LIKE HIM.
IT'S OBVIOUS.
HE'S VERY TRUSTWORTHY.
I THINK WE SHOULD ALL GO IN
ON THE DEAL.
I LOVE THAT IDEA.
I LOVE THAT IDEA, TOO.
I LIKE IT.
I'M IN.
I'LL DO YOUR ASK.
$250,000, 10%.
I'M IN ON THAT.
WELL, THAT'S FUNNY.
I WAS GONNA SAY 20%.
OH, SORRY.
LET ME TAKE THAT BACK.
[ CHUCKLES ]
I'M IN.
$250,000 FOR 20%.
ALL RIGHT.
LORI AND I ARE IN.
$250,000 FOR 20%.
BARB, YOU IN?
YEAH, DEFINITELY.
ALL RIGHT.
THAT'S THREE.
Greiner: MARK?
NO.
KEVIN?
MARK IS SO ARROGANT.
I'M NOT THERE.
I'M NOT ARROGANT.
OH, YES, YOU ARE.
IT'S JUST NOT WORTH THE TIME
AND EFFORT FOR THAT PERCENTAGE.
O'Leary:
WHAT DO YOU CARE MORE FOR?
I MEAN,
DO YOU WANT ONE SHARK?
DO YOU THINK THERE'S VALUE
IN MULTIPLE SHARKS?
THE DREAM, OF COURSE,
IS TO HAVE ALL THE SHARKS.
BUT $250,000 AT 20%,
IT'S -- THAT'S VALUING ALREADY
QUITE A BIT LOWER THAN --
I'VE ALREADY REDUCED
THE VALUE, TOO.
BUT YOU HAVE TO APPRECIATE,
ON OUR SIDE,
WE HAVE TO AT LEAST
BE INTERESTED...
OF COURSE.
...TO HELP YOU
WITH THE BUSINESS.
OF COURSE.
AND YOU'VE GOT THREE OF US
INTERESTED.
AND THAT'S SKINNY AS IT IS.
AND THAT'S AWESOME.
AND WE'RE ALL
FROM DIFFERENT CITIES.
WHICH IS VERY COOL.
A LOT OF INFLUENCE
IN EACH ONE OF THOSE CITIES.
Herjavec:
MAKE ME A COUNTER.
20%. I AGREE WITH YOU.
IT'S TOO HIGH.
I DON'T KNOW
WHAT I WAS THINKING.
WHY WAS I LISTENING
TO BARBARA AGAIN?
MAKE ME A COUNTER.
UM...$250,000 FOR 12%.
DONE.
OH!
HE DIDN'T SAY DONE.
I'LL DO IT ON MY OWN.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
$250,000, 12%.
WAIT A MINUTE.
I'LL DO IT RIGHT NOW.
ZANDER'S A SMART GUY.
THAT'S YOUR COUNTER.
I'M FROM CHICAGO. THAT'S WHERE
YOU WANT TO BE NEXT. SO --
WELL, YOU CAN COME IN WITH ME
ON THE DEAL.
YOU JUST CUT ME OUT.
$250,000 FOR 12%.
I'M HAPPY TO DO IT
ON MY OWN.
$250,000, 15%.
I'M HAPPY TO HAVE LORI
COME ALONG.
$250,000 FOR 15%?
ZANDER,
YOU'RE NOT CONSIDERING 20%?
UM, I WOULD HAPPILY DO 20%,
BUT FOR MORE CASH.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
Greiner: ZANDER --
ZANDER, I OFFERED YOU EXACTLY
WHAT YOU COUNTERED.
I OFFERED TO COME IN --
I WOULD LOVE MORE SHARKS
IN THE DEAL.
I OFFERED TO COME IN
AT 15% BECAUSE, FOR ME,
IF I'M SPLITTING WITH ROBERT,
NOT WORTH IT FOR LESS.
I KNOW THE TIME AND THE EFFORT
AND THE CARE
AND THE ATTENTION THAT I PUT IN,
AND I AM YOUR CUSTOMER.
I NEED TO HEAR AN ANSWER
ON MY OFFER.
O'Leary: WELL, LET ME ADD
SOME CLARITY TO IT...
AND YOURS WAS $250,000 FOR 15%.
IT WAS $250,000 FOR 15%.
...JUST TO HELP
CLEAR THE FIELD.
AND IT WAS ROBERT AND I
TOGETHER.
HAPPY TO GO ALONG
WITH LORI.
I WOULD PREFER $250,000 FOR 12%,
OF COURSE.
DONE.
WITH HIM.
WITH AS MANY SHARKS AS POSSIBLE.
IF ANYONE ELSE WANTS IN, GREAT.
NO ONE ELSE IS --
I'M OUT.
I'LL DO $250,000
FOR 12% RIGHT NOW.
DONE.
ALL RIGHT.
I LOVE THE IDEA.
LOVE THE IDEA.
THANKS, MAN.
THIS IS EXCITING.
VERY EXCITING.
ALL RIGHT?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT.
YOU'RE VERY WELCOME.
OKAY, ZANDER.
I'M OUT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
UNDERSTOOD.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
WHILE IT SEEMED LIKE
IT WAS POSSIBLE THAT MORE SHARKS
COULD GET INVOLVED
FOR MORE CASH,
I'M SUPER PSYCHED
TO HAVE ROBERT INVOLVED.
AND SO
I DIDN'T WANT TO TAKE THE RISK
OF HAVING EVERYTHING FALL APART.
Narrator:
NEXT UP IS A MARRIED COUPLE
WITH A COMPACT WAY TO EAT
A FAVORITE SNACK.
Nick: HI, SHARKS.
I'M NICK OLEKSAK,
AND THIS IS MY WIFE, ELYSE,
AND WE'RE THE CREATOR OF
BANTAM BAGELS FROM NEW YORK CITY
ON A MISSION TO...
Both:
CHANGE THE WAY YOU BAGEL!
WHOO!
WE'RE HERE TODAY ASKING
FOR $275,000
IN EXCHANGE FOR 11% EQUITY STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
AS COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY
GRADUATES,
WE HAVE LIVED IN NEW YORK CITY
FOR OVER 10 YEARS NOW.
SO, IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT
WE LOVE A GOOD NEW YORK BAGEL.
BUT THOSE HUGE, DOUGHY,
HIGH-CALORIE MONSTERS,
THEY'RE SUCH
A COMMITMENT.
AND WE FIND OURSELVES FIGHTING
THE SAME BATTLE --
TO BAGEL OR NOT TO BAGEL.
[ CHUCKLES ]
ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO,
A DREAM WOKE ME UP
IN THE MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
IT WAS A VISION
OF SOMETHING REVOLUTIONARY.
MINI...BAGEL BALLS
FILLED WITH CREAM CHEESE!
WOW.
WE KNEW THAT IF WE STARTED
WITH AN AUTHENTIC
NEW YORK-STYLE BAGEL
AND FINISHED WITH HIGH-QUALITY,
UNIQUE CREAM CHEESES
THAT BANTAM BAGELS
WOULD BE MORE
THAN JUST ANOTHER
FLASH-IN-THE-PAN FOOD FAD.
SO, WE TRADED
OUR APARTMENT KITCHEN
FOR A LITTLE SHOP
ON BLEECKER STREET.
AND LUCKY FOR US,
IN LESS THAN A YEAR,
WE WERE VOTED ONE OF THE TOP
THREE BEST BAGELS IN NEW YORK
BY THE NEW YORK DAILY NEWS.
WOW.
WE ARE NOW READY TO TAKE
OUR ONE-OF-A-KIND BAGELS
FROM COAST TO COAST.
SO, SHARKS, WE ASK YOU...
Both: ARE YOU READY
TO CHANGE THE WAY YOU BAGEL?
YOU GUYS WANT
TO TRY SOME?
YEAH.
OH, YEAH.
ABSOLUTELY.
SO, AS ELYSE IS PASSING THEM OUT
TO YOU GUYS,
THERE'S ONE TRICK TO EATING
A BANTAM BAGEL.
IMAGINE EATING A JELLY DOUGHNUT
FROM THE WRONG SIDE.
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE
ALL THE GOODNESS
THAT'S ON THE INSIDE
STAYS ON THE INSIDE.
FIND THE HOLE,
BITE THE HOLE.
[ LAUGHS ]
O'Leary:
FIND THE HOLE, BITE THE HOLE.
THAT'S THE HOLE RIGHT THERE.
YOU GOT IT.
Nick: THE HOLE
WHERE THE CREAM CHEESE IS.
OH, I WENT THE WRONG WAY.
SO I AM FINDING THE HOLE.
I AM BITING THE HOLE.
FIND IT AND BITE IT.
OH, WOW.
THAT'S REALLY GOOD.
THANK YOU, YEAH.
WOW.
THANK YOU.
THAT'S ONE
OF OUR BEST SELLERS.
IT'S CALLED THE --
IT'S CALLED THE FRENCH TOAST.
Greiner:
I JUST ATE THAT. MMM!
YEAH.
IT'S A NUTMEG,
EGG, CINNAMON BAGEL.
I LOVE IT.
I LOVE IT!
[ LAUGHS ]
Herjavec:
WHAT'S THIS ONE?
IT'S A CHEDDAR EGG BAGEL.
AND THEN CREAM CHEESE IS
A BACON CHEDDAR CREAM CHEESE.
O'Leary: HOW MANY
DIFFERENT VERSIONS DO YOU HAVE?
AT ANY GIVEN TIME, WE HAVE
ABOUT 18 ON THE SHELVES.
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S TALK NUMBERS.
HOW MUCH IS
THE BLEECKER STREET LOCATION
DOING IN REVENUE A YEAR?
FROM THE RETAIL SIDE,
SINCE INCEPTION,
WE HAVE DONE $200,000.
WHAT DOES IT COST
TO MAKE THESE?
EACH BANTAM COSTS 30 CENTS
TO MAKE.
Greiner: IF I WALK IN
AND I BUY ONE, WHAT IS IT?
$1.50.
ONE BALL COSTS $1.50?
YES.
AND PEOPLE BUY IT.
Herjavec: ARE THEY BUYING IT
BECAUSE IT'S A NOVELTY
OR DO PEOPLE
ACTUALLY COME BACK?
THEY'RE DEFINITELY COMING BACK.
WE HAVE OUR REGULARS.
A LOT OF MOMS AND KIDS.
WE HAVE
SO, WHAT'S THE GAME PLAN?
WHAT DO YOU NEED WITH $275,000?
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
WE'RE LOOKING TO BUILD
A COMMERCIAL COMMISSARY
BAKING FACILITY
SO THAT -- BASICALLY, RIGHT NOW,
IF WE WANT A BAG OF FLOUR,
THAT'S ALL WE CAN GET.
WE CAN'T GET
A PALLET OF FLOUR.
RIGHT. I GET IT.
AND WHAT HAPPENS AFTER YOU --
THAT WOULD INCREASE
YOUR CAPACITY BY 25 TIMES.
NOW WHAT HAPPENS?
MORE STORES?
OKAY.
WE KNEW AT THE BEGINNING
THAT WE WOULD HAVE TO TRY
A COUPLE DIFFERENT
STRATEGIC AVENUES.
SO, WE STARTED OFF THINKING,
"THIS RETAIL CHANNEL,
THAT'S RIGHT FOR US."
SO, WE TESTED IT OUT.
WE KILLED IT.
THE REVENUE WAS INCREDIBLE.
MARGINS, NOT SO MUCH.
WHY?
BECAUSE OF THE SEASONALITY
AND THE UNPREDICTABILITY
OF CUSTOMERS.
THERE WAS A --
LABOR WAS PRETTY HIGH.
SO, WE SMARTENED UP
AND SAID, "WE BETTER TRY
A DIFFERENT CHANNEL."
WE CLAWED AND SCRATCHED
AND GOT OUR WAY
INTO SOME PRETTY BIG
WHOLESALE AVENUES,
WHICH WE HAVE BEEN --
WHO?
THE, UM --
SO, OUR BIGGEST
WHOLESALE ACCOUNT IS QVC.
QVC?
HOW WELL ARE YOU SELLING
ON QVC?
OUR FIRST TIME ON THERE,
WE SOLD OUT IN FIVE MINUTES.
OKAY. HOW MANY ARE BEING BOUGHT?
WHAT PRICE?
WE SOLD A PACK OF 36,
$17.80 COST TO US,
AND QVC BUYS IT FOR $19.80.
SO, WE MAKE $2 PER PACK.
WHOA.
OH, LORD.
THAT SUCKS.
WELCOME TO QVC.
THAT'S ROUGH.
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT ANYMORE?
YOU DON'T NEED THAT.
BECAUSE
THERE'S NO BETTER WAY
TO GET IN FRONT
OF 8 MILLION PEOPLE.
LOOK. YOU MAY NOT SPEND
ANY TIME
DEVELOPING A DISTRIBUTION
STRATEGY OTHER THAN
DIRECT TO THE CONSUMER BECAUSE
YOU'RE ONLY GOING TO HAVE,
IF YOU'RE LUCKY,
$275,000 OF CASH.
THAT LETS YOU SET UP
ONE COMMERCIAL KITCHEN,
ONE WEBSITE,
AND FOCUS METICULOUSLY ON THAT
TO GET READY
FOR THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF "SHARK TANK" VIEWERS
WHO ARE GONNA WANT TO TRY THIS.
EVERYTHING ELSE
IS IRRELEVANT
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT MAKING
ANY MONEY ON ANYTHING ELSE.
Cuban: HOW MUCH HAVE YOU GUYS
INVESTED OF YOUR OWN,
OF YOUR MONEY,
AND WHERE DID IT COME FROM?
Nick:
$50,000 OF OUR OWN MONEY.
AND THEN, YOU KNOW, TO START
THIS, WE HAD TO RAISE MONEY.
SO, WE'RE BOTH
FROM WALL STREET.
WHERE DID YOU WORK
ON WALL STREET? WHAT DID YOU DO?
I WORKED AT MORGAN STANLEY
IN ASSET MANAGEMENT.
Nick: AND I'M ACTUALLY
STILL CURRENTLY WORKING
AS A CREDIT BROKER
AT GFI GROUP.
HOW MUCH DID YOU RAISE
FROM THE OTHER INVESTORS?
JUST UNDER $600,000.
AND WHAT DO THEY OWN?
WE'VE ALLOCATED
23% OF THE COMPANY.
ARE YOU, NICK, GONNA QUIT
YOUR JOB WHEN YOU HAVE THE BABY?
ABSOLUTELY.
Herjavec: NICK, DO YOU MAKE
A LOT OF MONEY ON WALL STREET?
I'M JUST CURIOUS.
I MEAN, I DON'T KNOW
WHAT YOU'D SAY IS --
SIX FIGURES.
YES.
HONESTLY, I AM SO READY
TO NOT WORK ON WALL STREET.
Corcoran: YEAH, BUT YOU HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD IT.
HOW ARE YOU GONNA PAY
YOUR RENT?
YOU KNOW,
WE HAVE SAVINGS.
Herjavec: HERE'S MY CHALLENGE
WITH YOU GUYS.
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE MAKING
THE KIND OF MONEY TODAY
THAT MOST PEOPLE WHO
COME ON TO THE "TANK"
WOULD ONLY DREAM OF.
AND THERE'S A LACK
OF DESPERATION
THAT YOU GET WHEN YOU'RE MAKING
SIX FIGURES AND HAVE MONEY.
YOU NEED
THAT SENSE OF DESPERATION.
YOU HAVE A GOLD MINE HERE
AND YOU'RE TRYING THIS,
"EH, IT KIND OF DOESN'T WORK.
WE'LL TRY THIS."
MAN,
WHEN YOU'RE STARTING OUT,
YOU'VE GOT TO FIND THAT ONE IDEA
AND YOU'VE GOT TO RUN WITH IT.
YOU'VE GOT TO GO, BABY.
CAN I SPEAK ABOUT IT
A LITTLE BIT?
AND RESPECTFULLY,
THAT'S SO DIFFICULT TO HEAR,
BECAUSE IF YOU ONLY KNEW --
EVERY DOLLAR WE DON'T MAKE
BLEEDS THROUGH OUR SYSTEM.
WE FEEL IT.
IT HURTS.
IF YOU THINK, FOR ANY MOMENT,
THAT THIS ISN'T WHO I AM
AND WHO I'VE POURED
THE LAST YEAR OF MY LIFE INTO,
THEN I'M JUST NOT
COMMUNICATING WELL TO YOU.
Cuban:
BUT, ROBERT, IT'S SO WRONG.
BECAUSE WHAT YOU'RE SAYING HERE
IS THAT NONE OF US HERE
CAN BE
GOOD ENTREPRENEURS ANYMORE.
NO, NO, NO. THAT'S NOT
WHAT I'M SAYING AT ALL, MARK.
WHAT I'M SAYING IS --
WE CAN'T DO A STARTUP?
WHAT I'M SAYING IS,
THIS IS A FANTASTIC IDEA.
THEY'RE TRYING
TOO MANY THINGS.
AND WE'RE WILLING TO LISTEN
TO YOUR INSIGHT.
WE'RE COACHABLE.
YOU KNOW, IF ONE OF YOU
FELT LIKE THIS IS IT,
THIS IS THE WAY TO GO,
WE TRUST THAT.
GUYS, THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
YOU JUST SAID,
"WE'RE COACHABLE."
YOU DON'T YET KNOW
WHERE THE BEST PLACE TO GO IS.
I THINK
YOU'LL FIGURE IT OUT,
BUT IT'S GONNA BE EXPENSIVE,
TIME-CONSUMING.
I DON'T WANT TO BE
IN THAT CIRCUMSTANCE
IN THE BAGEL BUSINESS
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
I CAN PROVIDE THAT DIRECTION
FOR YOU.
SO, FOR THOSE REASONS, I'M OUT.
OKAY.
I THINK YOU'RE GONNA GO THROUGH
A LOT OF DIFFERENT TRIES.
I CAN'T HELP YOU RIGHT NOW.
WISH YOU ALL THE BEST.
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
I'M GONNA MAKE YOU AN OFFER.
OH.
I'M REALLY
A PERFECT PARTNER.
YOU COULDN'T HAVE GONE TO BED
LAST NIGHT
AND HAD THE BEST DREAM OF YOUR
LIFE AND NOT HAVE ME IN IT.
[ GREINER LAUGHS ]
IT'S THE TRUTH.
THOSE ARE CALLED NIGHTMARES,
BARB.
I'VE WALKED
THAT ROAD EXACTLY,
IN THE SAME PATTERN
AS YOU'RE WALKING IT NOW,
WITH DAISY CAKE'S.
I'VE GONE TO HELL AND BACK AGAIN
WITH HER,
AND I KNOW EVERYTHING
YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO DO.
BUT I HAVE A FEW THINGS.
ONE, YOUR BRAND,
I DON'T LIKE.
SECONDLY, WOULD YOU BE WILLING
TO DROP QVC
AT THOSE SKINNY, LITTLE MARGINS
WITH ALL THAT PRESSURE?
THEY'RE NOT GONNA
LIKE THAT. THEY'RE NOT
GONNA LIKE THAT AT ALL.
LET THEM DECIDE FOR THEMSELVES,
LORI.
I'M JUST SAYING.
WE -- WE WOULD BE
WILLING TO.
Corcoran:
HERE'S MY OFFER.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $275,000,
BUT I WANT 51% OF YOUR GOODS.
OH!
I'M GONNA TELL YOU
WHY IT'S A GREAT OFFER --
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT GONNA SUCCEED
WITHOUT ME.
Narrator:
TWO SHARKS ARE OUT.
NICK AND ELYSE HAVE AN OFFER
FROM BARBARA --
$275,000, BUT FOR 51%
CONTROLLING INTEREST
OF THEIR MINI-BAGEL COMPANY,
BANTAM BAGELS.
Corcoran: I'M GONNA TELL YOU
WHY IT'S A GREAT OFFER --
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT GONNA SUCCEED
WITHOUT ME.
WELL, WE APPRECIATE YOUR OFFER,
BARBARA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
O'Leary: ALL RIGHT.
HERE'S WHAT I'M GONNA DO.
THERE'S ONLY THREE THINGS THAT
YOU HAVE TO DO TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
ONE,
YOU HAVE TO QUIT YOUR JOB.
TWO, YOU HAVE TO DO A COMMERCIAL
KITCHEN -- NOT OWN IT.
YOU HAVE TO FIND ONE
THAT ALREADY EXISTS.
YOU DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME
TO BUILD YOUR OWN, OKAY?
RIGHT.
AND THREE, YOU HAVE TO BE DIRECT
TO CONSUMER.
IF YOU DO ALL OF THOSE,
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $275,000
FOR 50%.
NOW, THAT'S TWO PEOPLE
IN YOUR BUSINESS...
THAT MAKES NO SENSE!
...TELLING YOU THAT WE NEED
THAT KIND OF PARTNERSHIP
TO MAKE THIS MAKE
ANY SENSE.
O'Leary: YOU WANT TO DO
WHAT WICKED CUPCAKES DID.
I'M LOOKING AT IT,
SAYING TO MYSELF, "OKAY.
"BEEN DOWN THIS ROAD ALREADY
WITH WICKED CUPCAKES.
SAME THING."
I DO IT AND MAKE MONEY --
LOTS OF MONEY.
OKAY.
I HAVE AN OFFER.
BUT I DON'T LIKE THE NAME,
EITHER,
BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
IT DESCRIBES WHAT IT IS.
AND TO ME, LIKE, CALLING IT,
YOU KNOW, STUFFIN' BAGEL,
BAGEL STUFFIN'S,
SOMETHING WHERE YOU GET IT.
THE OTHER THING THAT
I THINK WOULD BE AWESOME,
I LIKE THE IDEA OF FOOD TRUCKS
FOR YOU.
A GREAT COFFEE
AND STUFFED BAGELS?
WHO WOULDN'T WANT THAT?
SO, WHAT'S YOUR OFFER?
HERE'S MY OFFER.
$275,000 FOR 30%.
GUYS, YOU GOT TO MAKE A DECISION
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO.
Nick: OKAY.
WELL, BARBARA,
WE APPRECIATE YOUR OFFER,
BUT THERE'S NO WAY
WITH WHAT WE'VE PUT IN
AND WHERE WE SEE
THIS BUSINESS GOING
THAT WE CAN GIVE UP
51% OF THE COMPANY.
MAKE ME A COUNTER OFFER.
I COULD SO HELP YOU.
I'M GONNA WALK YOU
THROUGH THE BAKERIES.
I KNOW THE BAD GUYS,
THE GOOD GUYS,
THE GUYS WHO RIP YOU OFF,
THE GUYS WHO STEAL YOUR RECIPES.
WE ALL HAVE EXPERIENCE
THAT'S GOING TO HELP YOU
NO MATTER WHAT.
THE ONLY QUESTION IS, ARE
YOU GOING TO MAKE A COUNTER
OFFER TO 51% OR NOT?
UM, WOULD YOU BE WILLING
TO GO DOWN TO 25%?
WELL, IN ALL THE TIME
THAT WE JUST SAT HERE
AND I'VE HAD MY OFFER
OUT THERE --
WOULD YOU MIND?
I'M GOING TO --
LORI, I DON'T WANT TO --
I'M THINKING TO MYSELF,
"WE COULD HAVE SOLD
$100,000 WORTH ON QVC."
WOULD YOU --
WOULD YOU BE INTERESTED IN 25%?
I'LL GIVE YOU 1/3.
I WOULD IF YOU DECIDE RIGHT NOW
WITH ME.
YOU'RE DONE.
YOU HAVE A DEAL.
ALL RIGHT. YAY.
I LOVE THESE THINGS.
OH, AMAZING.
THESE THINGS
ARE AWESOME.
WE LOVE YOU.
DOGGONE.
CONGRATS, GUYS.
I THOUGHT
I WAS GONNA GET IT.
Nick:
I THINK WE MADE A GREAT DEAL.
WE WENT IN WITH A NUMBER
THAT WE WERE WILLING TO ACCEPT
WITH THE RIGHT PARTNER
AND THE RIGHT SHARK,
AND SOMEHOW THE STARS ALIGNED
AND WE GOT ALL OF IT.